la main d'œuvre étrangère en grossissant
le nombre des travailleurs est donc un
facteur de production et de croissance
elle pie une absence de candidature pour
certains emplois des Français en fait
nous sommes obligés d'employer des
étrangers car on s'aperçoit que la main
d'œuvre française s'adapte mal à notre
travail c'est peut-être un problème de
formation professionnelle c'est
peut-être un problème de salaire
toujours est-il qu'en ce qui nous
concerne en tous les cas sur ce chantier
les étrangers ont le même salaire que
les Français à qualification égale
on a besoin des
travailleurs étrangers il faut
lorsqu'ils travaillent pouvoir les
régulariser et est considéré de la même
manière que n'importe quel travailleur
mais oui il y a des métiers pour des
questions de pénibilité qui sont plus
désertés et c'est là où il faut qu'on
arrête ces débats à la conù on
considérerait que que c'est que c'est un
problème c'est sans doute une partie de
la solution à une seule condition c'est
qu'on les
[Musique]
régularise